we talked about
poncare conjecture
there's a guy he's russian grigori
perlman he proved pancreas conjecture if
you can comment
on the proof itself if that stands out
to you something interesting
or the human story of it which is he
turned down the fields medal
for the proof is there something
you find inspiring or insightful about
the proof itself
or about the man yeah i mean one thing
i really like about the proof and partly
that's because it's sort of a thing that
happens again and again
in this book i mean i'm writing about
geometry and the way it sort of appears
in all these kind of real world problems
and
but it happens so often that the
geometry you think you're studying
is somehow not enough you have to go one
level higher in abstraction and study a
higher level of geometry and the way
that plays out is that
you know poincare asks a question about
a certain kind of three-dimensional
object
is it the usual three-dimensional space
that we know or is it some kind of
exotic thing and so of course this
sounds like it's a question about the
geometry of the three-dimensional space
but no parallel understands and by the
way in a tradition that involves richard
hamilton and many other people
like most really important mathematical
advances this doesn't happen alone it
doesn't happen in a vacuum it happens as
the culmination of a program that
involves many people
same with wiles by the way i mean we
talked about wiles and i want to
emphasize that
starting all the way back with kumar who
i mentioned in the 19th century but
um gerhard frye and mazer and ken ribbit
and like many other people
are involved in building the other
pieces of the arch before you put the
keystone in will you stand on the
shoulders of giants
yes um
so what is this idea the idea is that
well of course the geometry of the
three-dimensional
object itself is relevant but the real
geometry you have to understand
is the geometry of the space of all
three-dimensional geometries
whoa you're going up a higher level
because when you do that you can say
now let's trace out a path
in that space yes um there's a mechanism
called richie flow and again we're
outside my research area so for all the
geometric analysts and differential
geometers out there listening to this
if i please i'm doing my best and i'm
roughly saying it
so this the ritchie flow allows you to
say like okay let's start from some
mystery three-dimensional space
which poincare would conjecture is
essentially the same thing as our
familiar three-dimensional space but we
don't know that
and now you let it flow you
sort of like let it move in its natural
path according to some almost physical
process
and ask where it winds up and what you
find is that it always winds up
you've continuously deformed it there's
that word deformation again
and what you can prove is that the
process doesn't stop until you get to
the usual three-dimensional space and
since you can get
from the mystery thing to the standard
space by this process of continually
changing
and never kind of having any sharp
transitions
then the original shape must have been
the same as the standard
shape that's the nature of the proof now
of course it's incredibly technical
i think as i understand it i think the
hard part is proving that
uh the favorite word of ai people you
don't get any singularities along the
way
um but of course in this context
singularity just means
acquiring a sharp kink it just means uh
becoming non-smooth at some point so
just saying something interesting about
uh formal about the smooth trajectory
through this weird space
yeah but but yeah so what i like about
it is that it's just one of many
examples
of where it's not about the geometry you
think it's about it's about the geometry
of all
geometries so to speak and it's only by
kind of like kind of like being jerked
out of flat land right same idea it's
only by sort of
seeing the whole thing globally at once
that you can really make progress on
understanding like the one thing you
thought you were looking at
it's a romantic question but what do
what what do you think about him turning
down the fields metal
is uh is that just our nobel prizes and
feelings medals just
just the cherry on top of the cake and
really math itself
the process of uh curiosity of pulling
at the string of
the mystery before us that's the cake
and then
the awards are just icing
and uh clearly i've been fasting and i'm
hungry
but but do you think it's
um it's it's tragic or just just a
little curiosity that he turned on the
medal
well it's interesting because on the one
hand i think it's absolutely true that
right in some kind of like
vast spiritual sense like awards are not
important
like not important the way that sort of
like understanding the universe is
important
um on the other hand most people who are
offered that prize accept it you know
it's it is so there's something unusual
about his uh
his choice there um i i wouldn't say i
see it as
tragic i mean maybe if i don't really
feel like i have a clear picture of
of why he chose not to take it i mean
it's not he's not alone
in doing things like this people
sometimes turn down prizes for
ideological reasons
um probably more often in mathematics i
mean
i think i'm right in saying that peter
schulze like turned down sort of some
big monetary
prize because he just you know i mean i
think he
[Music]
at some point you have plenty of money
and maybe you think it sends the wrong
message about what the point of doing
mathematics
is um i do find that there's most people
accept you know most people given a
prize most people take it i mean people
like to be appreciated but
like i said we're people yes not that
different from most other people
but the important reminder that that
turning down the prize
serves for me is not that there's
anything wrong with the prize
and there's something wonderful about
the prize i think the no
the nobel prize is trickier because so
many nobel prizes are given
first of all the nobel prize often
forgets many many of the
important people throughout history
second of all there's like these weird
rules to it that's only three people and
some projects have a huge number of
people and it's like this
it um i don't know it it doesn't
kind of highlight the way science is
done on some of these projects in the
best possible way
but in general the prizes are great but
what this kind of teaches me and reminds
me is
sometimes in your life there'll be
moments
when the thing that you
you would really like to do society
would really like you to do
is the thing that goes against something
you believe in
whatever that is some kind of principle
and stand your ground
in the face of that it's something
i believe most people will have a few
moments like that in their life
maybe one moment like that and you have
to do it that's what integrity is
so like it doesn't have to make sense to
the rest of the world but to stand on
that like
to say no it's interesting because i
think you know that he turned down the
prize
in service of some principle because i
don't know that
well yes that seems to be the inkling
but he has never made it super clear but
the the inkling is that there
he had some problems with the whole
process of mathematics that
includes awards like this hierarchies
and
reputations and all those kinds of
things and individualism that's
fundamental to american culture
he probably because he visited the
united states quite a bit
that he probably you know
it's like all about experiences and
he may have had you know some parts of
academia
some pockets of academia can be less
than inspiring perhaps sometimes
because of the individual egos involved
not academia people in general
smart people with egos and if they
if you interact with a certain kinds of
people you can become cynical too easily
i'm one of those people that i've been
really fortunate to interact with
incredible people at mit and academia in
general but
i've met some [ __ ] and i tend to
just kind of when i when i
run into difficult folks i just kind of
smile and send them all my love and just
kind of go
go around but for others those
experiences can be sticky
like they can become cynical about the
world
when uh folks like that exist so it's he
he may have uh he may have become a
little bit cynical about the process of
science
you